[Music]
ukraine's railroad has become a lifeline
for refugees
all these stations are gateways to
safety that lead to lev which has become
a vital way out of the country
from here most travel to shemeshl a
small polish town eight miles from the
ukrainian border
its train station has transformed into a
relief center inside volunteers welcome
the refugees and offer them food as they
figure out where to go next
many have brought their pets on the long
journey
but they've only brought as much as they
can carry
like marina and her son
who spent the night here at the train
station after leaving everything behind
naturally
[Music]
spent six hours waiting in an underpass
on her journey here
were asleep in their homes when their
city came under fire
as russia continues to move further into
ukraine this critical web of escape
routes is increasingly under attack
making it harder and harder for millions
of ukrainians to escape the invasion
[Music]
since russia invaded ukraine on february
24th more than 3 million people have
fled their homes
nearly all of them are moving west away
from russia and towards these countries
over here
and the vast majority around 2 million
are going here
to poland
most of them are women and children
ukraine is requiring most men between
the ages of 18 and 60 to stay behind and
encouraging them to fight
since the war began ukraine has closed
its airspace to civilian flights and the
roads have become increasingly dangerous
railway stations are the most important
points in the country so far because
people
can get on the train on these cities and
move to west and save their lives
that's alexander commission he's in
charge of a mobile command team that has
evacuated more than 2 million people by
train we focus on different cities
depending on the bombing once new cities
are under shelling we increase the
capacity for these cities things change
so fast ukrainian railways releases a
daily schedule and so far the most
popular roads are kiev live
at the stations people are packed into
evacuation trains
and it's in large part because of
alexander's policy all people who would
like to leave the city can do it within
one day so we finish the day with zero
people on the railway station
but it's not just about getting on the
train the journey itself is getting more
dangerous too
on march 13th russian forces hit an
evacuation train here
killing the conductor and stranding
hundreds
further north near kharkiv an
undetonated bomb landed right by the
train tracks a few days earlier
ukrainian railway workers had to defuse
and remove it
damaged tracks like these can
temporarily stop escape routes we got
the greatest team of infrastructure
professionals who start repairing the
track once the plumbing stops and they
do it in hours not these but bomb
bridges like this one can shut them down
permanently
the areas over here where russia is
fighting for control are especially
dangerous for trains to reach
as a result most of these stations shut
down soon after the war began
including mikolaiv the port city martina
and sabina fled
[Music]
their parents drove them to odessa where
the train station was still operating so
they could make it to levitt
poland has become the top destination
for refugees because it has a very long
border with ukraine it's also culturally
and linguistically similar and already
has over a million ukrainians living and
working in the country
but it's also because soon after russia
invaded ukraine the eu did something
unprecedented europe will be there for
them not only in the first days but also
in the weeks and months to come they
activated this directive which provides
temporary protection it was first issued
in 2001 after a decade of wars in
southeastern europe displaced millions
of people the directive allowed for
temporary protection for people fleeing
from non-eu countries but it was never
invoked until now
what the temporary protection directive
offers is a range of rights that are
applicable immediately and these include
residency rights right to have access to
the labor market right to health care
social protection but also right to
education what is also notable is that
this mechanism was adopted by all the eu
member states
this means that the millions of people
fleeing ukraine can continue on to any
of the 27 eu countries with these
protections for up to three years
this is a testimony to the large scale
of the crisis that we're seeing now in
europe
but despite this directive not all
seeking refuge have been treated the
same way on the ground many
non-ukrainians have experienced racism
as they fled reports include being
pushed to the back of the lines at the
border and being turned away at hotels
in chemical though thousands keep
arriving every day
says
for many refugees arriving in chemical
this is just the first stop out of
ukraine
martina and sabina have family in poland
to help them get started
but the vast majority will go on to
reception centers or move deeper into
europe
and farther away from home
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
some people cry some people smile some
people are happy some people are not
happy but finally all the people who
left the cities which are shelves they
can sleep at least
in a calm place and without a vomit
that's the most important thing we keep
in mind that gives me
understanding that we do right job
[Music]
foreign
yeah